[Music]
it is a double-elimination
[Music]
it definitely hasn't sunk in I think it
may in a few days but it's sad and it's
unfortunate we put in work we put in so
much work we put in constant non-stop
massive giant efforts I just truly have
loved my time here I've loved this
journey that I've been on I've loved
learning how to dance and I love
everything about this guy he's awesome
and amazing and so sweet what have I
learned about myself it's okay to be
uncomfortable and go out of your comfort
zone when you think you can you totally
can and I mean look at what I'm wearing
right now and I have like freckle glue
marks it's you know it's okay to be
silly and make fun of yourself but as
long as you're having fun that's all
what matters on one hand I'm shocked
because I was so excited to get to the
finals potentially and go that level but
on the other hand it's bittersweet
because I get to snuggle with my kids
until like noon tomorrow I might you
know what we're gonna stay in PJs all
day what do you want people to remember
most about this partnership max
resilience man
but I just said it it was hard although
it came so unexpected I felt one of the
biggest kind of transformations in my
student 2 we went into some obstacles in
the beginning but we found I had two
left feet he was like you can't dance
but we found our rhythm and then we
started to improve steady
this was great this was I wouldn't have
a season any other way
[Music]
you